- Good morning, Believe Nation!
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn how to stand up
for what you believe.
Over to you, Bernie Sanders.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Espresso keep me going.
- (Audience member)
What advice do you have
for young people who have
a passion for politics,
and potentially want to
pursue careers in politics
and public service?
- This is my advice.
I don't like the word
passion for politics.
What I prefer is -
and you've got to got to
your heart on this one -
passion for justice.
Okay?
(audience clapping and cheering)
I have talked to a lot of you.
You know, when you're a senator,
you talk to a lot of people.
Had kids come up to me,
they say, "Oh, I want to be a
governor. I want to be president.
"I want to be a senator."
And that doesn't interest me at all.
What interests me is
when somebody tells me
they're concerned about the
healthcare crisis in America,
or they're concerned about poverty.
How can they do something about that?
There's a lot of ways you do it.
One of the ways is running
for office, not the only way.
We're raising the minimum
wage to 15 bucks an hour,
but not because of political decisions.
It started with grassroots
activism, actually.
Then politics kicked in.
So I would say to answer your question,
is number one,
go into your gut.
Go into your gut, and
that's not necessarily easy.
What do you believe?
What do you really believe?
Think about it.
It's not something you know right away.
What are your passions?
Do you have the courage
to stand up to people
who want to reject you or push you around?
Okay?
And if you have those qualities, jump in.
I mean politics and getting
involved has been to me
an extraordinary ride.
When I was there in Burlington,
you know what we did?
We literally broke down
the door of city hall.
We almost literally did that.
We took on an entire
establishment, which by the way,
to answer the question
was a Democratic Party.
And we pushed them aside.
We brought hundreds and hundreds of people
into the local process.
We started programs for
young people, for old people,
for women, in the
environment, for the arts.
It was an extraordinary experience,
which has so much excitement,
so much energy. Alright?
It's a lot of fun.
But the main thing you have to do,
don't do it if you're just
thinking about in a career.
You follow what I'm saying?
- [Audience Member] Yes
- Think about it as a mechanism.
One way that you can bring
change to this world.
And if that's what you want,
go for it and have the
guts to stand up and fight
for what you believe.
(audience cheering)